non c'è l'italiano miliardi lingue
dall'italiano solo sono ingoiato cagato
è rimangiato perfetto andiamo gli
english che tanto metri però mi fa
perche i più cari a perdere questo video
sono va dj e oggi siamo su palatu stiamo
diritto gioco e da un gioco di legno
bello questo so io che sarà versione
brutta di shrek introduzione clicca sul
diesel
credo che sia il corso per tenere il
dipinto per cominciare bene ma io
disegno le cose e ci vedono anche
l'impasto destra che figata
guarda che disegnarle giorgio bene
questo è il mio quadro c'è qualcosa in
contrario no vai a lo metto in vendita
capello name best 4ever comprate
comprate è coperto è passato nel budget
man che cazzo fai copre quanta mite
baguette trarsi da ogni 9 donna dal
minore valenza il tema pop
[Musica]
hanno fatto mendicando io grazie alla
rete 4 che devo fare i soldi quali ma
lei provava è meta dietro lo penso io da
dietro ogni teoria doveva andar bene
come qua c'è non è mai la banda per me
da dietro troviamo a rendere questo
titolo un po più brutti bay il barbone
che voi comprarmi quadro copre quattro
esami quel quei soldi agosto blando
compri veda dietro alla fine contro te è
stato tutto abbastanza 6 euro
ho capito il mondo della pittura come
funziona non serve che il quadro sia
antico per venderlo basta che abbiano
titolo feedback ritratto di quest'uomo
che sempre che sia un uomo che sta
camminando nel mio giardino
ok ragazzo vito permettere più nei loro
è quello che patella di qua fuori quindi
giochiamo lo chiamiamo quello che
passeggia qua fuori sono sempre
flashlight warlick baguette ti piace a
te quello è lo so che ti piace perché
dipingi del trap azione da gol
lo faccio per goal.com ragazzo è big
amica come youtube e dove vanno personal
dipingo per passione testa di minchia
e va bene te lo vendo addetti e di
compratelo testa di culo se vai a
drogarsi da qualche parte fra citiamolo
e natura morta creta è una lancia teria
è questa un arancio che quindi signori
qua non so quale trovate di meglio
facciamo una cura natura torta è previta
8 dollari dai map ingari valotto dollari
oggi arancia me chiavica pieni a ben di
questo lo prendi più vero
pronto non va a prendere anche perché
devo comprarmi un quadro di queste di
tutto che visto videogioco non mi piace
se tira dominati sta già giocando perché
non raggiungete problemi al giorno
d'oggi è difficile io non riesco a
capire
passio hominis a questo andamento di
istinti omicidi a colorare fa colorare
però a questi pittori di oggi ho
finalmente uno a cui piace la mia
arancia meccanica mecchia di capolona
bene ben fornita caspri 09 le balle alla
rai anche non so quanto siamo lì i
guadagni eccolo 37 o prendiamo quella di
37 euro
la madonna meno pregnante quando 7 ott
avendo subito mica se faccio sterni me
lo vende 88 casabella confronti fatto è
venduto per 76 2 case agli oli mila euro
in più da sat ha detto dammi i miei cosi
possiamo vederci volutamente il prezzo
del quadro sul quadro voglio dire quanto
meno 400 tra via
navigon del gestito centro gestito 4
euro è che perché stefano tra le
siringhe i 4 euro sbaglio ragazzi e toni
f ho fatto le parti a quell effetto le
fa le perfette un sacco francese squadra
non so permette vendono sacro blair welt
e rodigina di ternate che sicuramente i
francesi affretteranno a che cosa è
costretto il rischio per oggi a causa
dei temi di prende male ma cane 89 altri
kohler ho sbagliato devo fare in tante
attività non sono antica ma si fa la mia
bandiera malizia peste che ci aggiungo
non poche tinti di tawke abiti creati ha
bisogno di una pausa per capire le mie
intenzioni riguardo il mio futuro da
vittoria perché qua la piece gli do un
sacco di di merda dalle navi e lo l'ater
erano dedicate prenderlo nel culo
[Musica]
procedimento trarre contento italia in
poche parole abbiamo pronti sempre
originale ma patta
ma basta non è mangiati riveli
cattoliche informati danno in francia
mangiati quello maledizione licata
fisici che l'arte del clown iniqua scopo
è stato visto il mio quartiere ma di
cibo so io la trinità patteggiare 4 0 il
cesena cofie vanno in meta inglese né da
parte civili non è una coppietta perché
della tua mamma fai lavora in
tangenziale e ce ne stanno altri
tangenziale che tornano stacco viale a
la mamma una persona di tempo pagarci
d'acqua mode non come
rimane diffusa mi min chiamati sodio
fatto 91 madonna ragazze il debito
nell'art brut augurio che voi abbiate
mai visto ma il prezzo non andavano
fatti per la tettonica bye bye bye bye
bye ole ole le france la viva la fismo
minchia vai così press laica bordin fa
getter certo tipo contro tale bimbo lite
ha soldi 53 ma non ho idea
guardate un'equazione tori vincendo lo
faccio per voi a gesù si 24 25 andretti
5 mai fatto un affare
hai fatto un affare zio di fake è dato
invece le cose più bello che ho fatto
finale va bene la pizza novella inculate
[Musica]
quel momento subito sito anche nelle
prestazioni sessuali che voi originale e
anni di bai ling solo perché non ce
l'hai visto quando gli dico di react di
cose via bedeschi pre di voi di carta
avete aspettando di fare una baguette ma
non erano sempre per niente una baguette
o vivaci e questa cosa mi fa rizzare i
baffi ma guarda nutro guerra della libia
hai fatto un affare appetibili caldo e
di come contenta domani a praga il
tentativo era quello di fare gandal non
so quanto sia diventato grande anche
questo ragazzi questo non è gandalf e
gangi sotto effetto di lsd vai occhi
ecco lo so che sei tu lo so perché la
stessa barba 200 220 perduto grandissimo
fatto da sempre in chiaro con gaza
capire che possiamo concludere che con
l'episodio di basta un vero che gli è
piaciuto e mi piace anche anche per le
varie opere che avete vinto tanto e
video se non deve più che decide diavolo
il prossimo 4 e magari velo complete voi
perché io devo buttarli in qualche modo
da ragazzi
[Musica]
d